you guys are not gonna believe this team
avatar is back
hey everybody its charlie we have the
best possible news we have an early
preview of scenes that they're filming
for the Avatar The Last Airbender
Netflix series so we'll break it down of
course I'll be doing all kinds of videos
for the series just like I did for
Legend of Korra in the original Avatar
The Last Airbender series so if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything because they
are ramping up quickly I'll also talk
about the actual release date after I
talk about the scenes that they were
filming so starting with number 8 big
breakdown there was a person working on
set probably production assistant that
recorded all the stuff that they were
doing so r.i.p to him but his job died
so that we could see what's going on
with a new avatar the last airbender
series so I'll just read what his
message was when he posted this on the
internet he says I got a chance to work
on a visual effects test for the new
live-action series and I thought I'd
share the experience probably going to be
the last experience that he has with
this particular effects house but he
says we've filmed some test scenes in a
huge screen studio in Los Angeles one in
Fire Lord Ozai throne room and the other
in the tundra with Katara and Sokka all
the backdrops were keyed digitally Oh
crazy that there is no real-life place
that they can go to to do that
particularly the fire Lords palace 7 the
actors James Luke played Fire Lord Ozai
Kevin Garner played Sokka and Kate
Bharati played Katara you may have seen
James Liu if you've watched a lot of old
martial arts films he's pretty badass
but most of the time now when he's not
working as an actor he works as a stunt
coordinator the biggest thing that he
did lately was coordinating all the
fights for Marvel's Luke Cage series on
Netflix so he's done a lot of Netflix
work before the actors that they had
playing Sokka and Katara's a new but
they give you a good idea for how young
the actors are going to be in the actual
series they were just using those people
as stand-ins so there'll be different
actors when the series actually
premieres because they're still casting
the series right now the throne room
scene consisted of a bunch of test shots
of Fire Lord Ozai sitting on the throne
they said they saw him doing a bunch of
weird stuff that probably won't make it
into the actual series they just wanted
to get a sense for what it was going to
look like inside his palace because
obviously you see this on the riser here
with his throne everything around it is
going to be replicated digitally
this isn't what it's going to look like
on the actual series this is gem just
testing out digital environment
replacement for his throne room just to
make it look really really crazy also
pretty sure they're not going to make fire
lord ozai where we're looking hat like
that in the actual episodes the six
Sokka and Katara's seen had dialogue and
a bunch of action they were bickering
about sokka's boomerang and how they
needed to hunt for fish when a group of
quote-unquote Marauders spotted them and
chased them away
Katara yelled threw up a wall of ice to
protect them waterbending Sokka freaked
out and said Katara you're a waterbender
as if they'd never seen her waterbend
before and this was the first time even
Katara was surprised that she was able
to water Ben the Marauders freaked out
and take off and they're saved
so five right away he realized that some
of those scenes weren't in the original
episodes or in the case of the fire lord
ozai scene they were filming that didn't
happen till way later in the first
season and Fire Lord Ozai himself didn't
really appear in an episode in a really
big way as Mark Hamill till future
seasons based on Mike and Brian's
synopsis of the series that they
released last year when they first
announced hey we're bringing Avatar The
Last Airbender back on Netflix they said
it's going to be a deeper retelling of the
original Avatar The Last Airbender
series but that only ran for 61 episodes
of half-hour animation the new Netflix
series will be hour-long live-action and
going deeper as you probably guessed
means they'll be adding a lot of
material to the original store time with
each of the team avatar members as they
learn more about their own individual
bending styles like spending way more
time with Toph once she shows up in a
future season and starts learning more
about her earthbending it eventually
learns how to metalbend we already spent
a ton of time in the original series
with Zuko practicing his firebending
lightning bending same thing with Azula
so it won't be quite as big of a change
for those characters so what might be
going on with them having Katara
learning to be a waterbender for the
first time in the first season might
just be a parallel for Aang's story
learning to waterbend during the first
season for like they said when they
released all these scenes these are
supposed to be temp actors even though
James Liu is a total martial arts badass
Netflix is spending Game of Thrones
level money on this series so they will
probably cast a much more recognizable
actor for Fire Lord Ozai I did see
someone
according a rumor that mark hamill was
going to actually come back and be live
action fire lord ozai because he was the
voice of the character on the animated
series
Prince Zuko you've been among the earth
Kingdom commoners do you think that
adding more troops will stop these
rebellions but based on what Mike and
Brian have said about the new episodes I
don't believe that at all
it will probably wind up being a
relatively high profile Asian actor same
goes for Sokka and Katara's but the ages
of these actors give you a pretty good
idea for how old they'll be at the
beginning of the series actors in their
late teens early 20s playing characters
in their mid-teens Sokka was only 16 at
the beginning of season 1 of the
animated series Katara was only 14 they
might age them up a couple years but
they'd still be teenagers still pretty
close to their original agent much as
young actors can become great martial
artists I fully expect them to use every
last trick in modern technology in every
giant bag of money they can to make the
actual martial arts and bending effects
look really really cool in ignoring what
that all looked like during the original
live-action movie don't waste your time
going back and watching that standard
practice in Hollywood is usually they
just get a really badass stunt double
and perform a lot of digital facial
replacement for the craziest fight
scenes best example that is a couple of
years ago during Game of Thrones Season 7 they released a featurette for the
Arya vs. Brienne fight Maisie Williams
trained as much as she could to actually
do the scene but they had a stunt double
that was basically her same size do the
fight scene and then they just swapped
Maisie Williams face onto her face so it
looked like she was actually doing this
the whole time probably going to be the
exact same situation with a live-action
Avatar The Last Airbender series they
also do a lot of this digital
environment replacement where they have
you know green screen or blue screen and
then they have this crazy planet or a
crazy building that they're inside so I
wouldn't be super worried about what
everything is going to look like it
sounds like they have the right
technology and they're spending the
right amount of money and I believe that
Sifu key sue is also coming back to
advise on a lot of their actual martial
arts fights in the bending styles what
differentiates the essences of these
different martial arts forms firebending
of course we
use the dynamic and artistic movements
of the northern Shaolin style the
powerful kicks the punches the low
stances the nearly acrobatic movements
did cuts through the center of mass of
the opponent that slices right through
to release date and episode count
there's a landing page that Netflix
created for the series that says 2020
next freaking year that is crazy I was
not expecting it to premiere until 2021
at the rate that they were going to last
time Mike and Brian posted a production
update but if they're planning on
releasing it next year that means that
they have to finish casting really
really soon and start shooting before
the end of the year the only way they'd
be able to shoot and edit all those
episodes by the end of next year is if
they're only doing eight to ten episodes
per season Netflix did the exact same
thing with The Witcher series and Henry
Cavill they only did eight episodes for
their season one but it took them less
than a year to turn it around and do all
those special effects I even saw some
newspaper claiming that they were going
to release the Avatar The Last Airbender
series next summer which seems crazy I
think that they'll have a trailer to
bring to comic-con next summer
but unless Mike and Bryan come out and
say something different I'm not
expecting it to premiere till the end of
next year so number one season one story
arc early predictions if they're
retelling the original story they only
do around ten episodes per season
expanding the original half-hour
episodes to a full hour
planning on five to six seasons instead
of the original three they'd either have
to a end the first season with the
two-parter Winter Solstice episodes
where Aang gets the Avatar Roku message
and then they come to the fire temple to
learn about sozin's comet and his path
as the avatar is laid out they learned
that they had to make it to the Northern
Water Tribe to teach Aang how to
waterbend so that he can become a fully
actualized avatar and defeat Fire Lord
Ozai before he becomes too powerful or B
they could try to end the first season
with the original season 1 finale the
siege of the Northern Water Tribe but
that almost feels like it's moving
through the material way too fast and it
would cause them problems down the road
in later seasons so everybody post your
predictions about what they're going to do
with the first season what do you think
the finale is going to be do you think
that they're going to end with the
Winter Solstice or do you think they're
going to try and speed through and end
with this
each of the north and I will do more
update videos in the production if we
get more previews more scenes more
teasers that'll all start happening a
little bit later this year when they
start filming
everybody click here to learn about the
special Azula storyline that they had
originally planned for Avatar The Last
Airbender season 4 when there was going
to be a season 4 and click here to learn
about what's going on with the
Spider- Man character at Marvel and Sony thank you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight!